bon bah écoutez bonjour à tous
je
privilège de présider cette audition en
remplacement de Rémi quattro qui est le
président de cette mission d'information
sur la gestion durable de l'eau et dont
notre rapporteur est un vilaine à mes
côtés en fait tout le boulot c'est lui
qui le fait avec l'administrateur
et puis toute l'équipe bien sûr mais
voilà tous les cas moi j'ai beaucoup de
plaisir à présider cette cette audition
de ce matin
nous nous présenterons les uns les
autres tout à l'heure vous pourrez vous
présenter mais
nous poursuivons donc notre cycle
d'audition sur la question de l'eau
débuter des le 28 février dernier
avec aujourd'hui une table ronde qui
réunit donc les entreprises qui assure
la fourniture d'eau potable dans
beaucoup de nos communes
il y a des communes en régie il reste
encore des communes en régie et des
communes en délégation de service public
qui font appel à vos services comme je
vous le disais notre président Rémy donc
un empêchement et donc j'ai la plaisir
d'assurer la présidence de notre séance
de jour puisque j'en suis vice-président
je rappelle qu'il s'agit d'une audition
publique
faisant l'objet d'un compte-rendu et
d'une retransmission
elle s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
mission d'information sur la gestion
durable de l'eau
demandée par le groupe socialiste
qui aboutira à la remise d'un rapport
fin juin début juillet
oui c'est ça tout à fait
c'est ça c'est à dire ça va c'est très
ce que je disais tout de suite
il ça lui fait des auditions de de
très très
proche les unes des autres et en très
grand nombre parce que c'est un dossier
actuellement
très sensible
on voit bien l'actualité autour de tout
ça c'est vrai que vous l'aviez vous
choisit avant que tout ça va on savait
que c'était une situation compliquée
mais avant que tout ça se déclenche
comme je le disais donc l'eau est dans
la tourmente
dans le tourmente avec le changement
climatique bien sûr mais aussi avec des
nouvelles problématiques de lutte contre
les polans et globalement une prise de
conscience
qu'on en a pas fait assez depuis
10-15 ans 20 ans moi-même je suis j'ai
été pendant 10 ans président de la
commission locale de l'eau de la baie de
Saint-Brieuc j'en ai fait des choses
déjà mais mais
on en a pas encore assez fait
donc le président de la République
d'ailleurs à
présenter un plan de 53 mesures la
semaine dernière alors la question qu'on
se pose nous et que tout le monde se
pose c'est normal c'est est-ce que ce
plan répond aux enjeux ou est-ce qu'il
faut le renforcer le le compléter voir
le corriger les questions qu'on peut
qu'on peut se poser
un questionnaire vous a été adressé qui
pourra servir de tram pour notre
entretien d'ailleurs
et comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure le principal
sénateur dans cette affaire c'est le
rapporteur
originel je disais André tout à l'heure
j'ai dit
et donc je vais passer tout de suite la
parole à Hervé qui va qui va mener cette
table ronde
très bien merci monsieur le Président
cher Alain donc après c'est popo
luminaires c'est vrai que nous sommes
dans un moment qui est particulier avec
en plus une sécheresse hivernale qui a
contribué à en termes d'information et
de communication à mettre ce sujet sur
la place publique donc on est dans un
moment intéressant et puis avec
l'annonce certes décalé mais du
président de la République sur le plan
haut on voit bien aussi quels sont les
sujets aujourd'hui d'accroche qui
mériteront sans doute au travers de
notre mission d'information aussi un
approfondissement pour aller aussi un
peu plus loin sur sur certains aspects
je voudrais remercier bien sûr pour
votre
disponibilité peut-être qu'avant de
passer sur le cycle des questions on va
d'abord vous laisser le soin de vous
présenter
et puis ça permettra aussi à nos
collègues de pouvoir avoir
ce retour en termes de présentation
qui est là
on démarre je vous en prie qui démarre
pour les présentations
au bout alors peut-être
n'oubliez pas oui le micro puisque tout
est enregistré voilà je vous en prie
merci merci monsieur le sénateur donc
Dominique Gatel du groupe Veolia merci
bonjour Pierre et botte je suis
directeur général de l'activité au
français
pour le groupe Suez
directeur technique que Suez
[Musique]
on voit bien qu'on a une évolution
aujourd'hui au niveau de la gestion
délégué qui s'impose encore dans notre
pays mais il y a un glissement
progressif aussi au niveau des régies
donc ça c'est une situation intéressante
à observer
donc vous avez forcément des éléments
d'analyse sur sur ces sujets là on voit
aussi des modalités en fait à la fois de
coopération des nouveaux modèles qui
s'installent c'est que certes s'il y a
des régies qui s'installe elle
s'installe aussi avec des appuis en
termes de compétences de votre part
entre autres et donc on est sur des
nouveaux modèles aussi peut-être
d'organisation donc c'est intéressant
peut-être
d'y revenir donc comment vous voyez
cette évolutions ces impacts avant que
nous passions à la gestion quantitative
et qualitative de l'eau
voilà pour sa première question
vous voulez quelques mots de
présentation générale peut-être
voilà mais assez synthétique si vous
voulez bien
très bien donc Veolia Eau France
une entreprise de service spécialisés
tout de suite évoqué des sujets de
gestion délégués on pourrait revenir
mais notre métier c'est une entreprise
de service donc nous aidons les
collectivités qui sont majoritairement
ils sont majoritairement nos clients en
France à opérer leurs services d'eau et
d'assainissement dans ta zone la
responsabilité
notamment la personne responsable la
production et la distribution d'eau
potable c'est la collectivité nous on
vient apporter ses services à ses
collectivités qui sont propriétaires des
actifs et qui ont la responsabilité du
service et donc on apporte pour ça je
dis nous sommes une entreprise de
service spécialisée dans l'eau et
l'assainissement quel type de service
nous offrons
de la relation aux usagers de ce service
public pour le compte de la collectivité
ça peut être aussi la facturation
l'encaissement des factures la
redistribution des différentes parts aux
agences les taxes les parts on va dire
local communautaire par exemple
la production
de l'eau potable c'est à dire
l'exploitation des unes aux production
d'eau potable la distribution de cette
eau potable et puis si on ferme la
boucle des services de collecte des eaux
usées
la gestion évidemment des événements
extrêmes qui peuvent impacter ce réseau
des eaux usées je pense évidemment aux
événements plus vieux le l'épuration
dans les stations d'épuration de ces de
ces eaux usées et en France ça se
termine par
99,7 ou 8% en fonction de quiconque et
comment mais ça se termine par un rejet
ou mieux naturel du nombre qui est donc
conforme à ces conditions de rejet alors
nous notre métier c'est d'intervenir sur
tout ou partie de ces éléments là vous
l'avez évoqué monsieur le rapporteur un
évoquant
au-delà de la gestion déléguée de des du
soutien du support qu'on peut fournir
aux différents opérateurs par exemple
public
nous fournissons l'équivalent enfin nous
intervenons sur l'équivalent d'un
périmètre d'un tiers de la population
française aussi bien pour nos services
d'eau et d'assainissement pour le compte
des collectivités territoriales et nous
sommes à peu près 15000 collaborateurs
sur le territoire national
donc au plus près du terrain c'est une
organisation très déconcentrée voilà qui
épouse
l'organisation des services en fait
voilà nos équipes sont là où le service
et c'est-à-dire là où les
infrastructures sont
voilà ce que je peux vous dire pour
notre activité vous vous
disiez tout à l'heure les collectivités
sont propriétaires des actifs donc des
réseaux on est bien d'accord
et l'entretien des réseaux reste à la
charge des collectivités on est d'accord
alors il y a deux là on rentre dans dans
une thématique en fait ouais ça dépend
voilà ça dépend des contrats et donc il
y a on va dire dans l'entretien il y a
l'entretien patrimonial
l'entretien on va dire c'est tout ce qui
est
les grosses les grosses interventions
par exemple des tronçons qui seraient
vieux ou très très endommagés qui sont
remplacés voilà donc ça on considère
c'est la gestion patrimoniale et puis
ensuite il y a les la gestion courante
l'entretien préventif ou curatif qui est
quelque chose qui fuit qui est cassé un
poste de relevage un poste de relevage
par exemple c'est c'est en fait dedans
voilà si vous devez le casser le
reconstruire on considère que c'est
plutôt patrimonial si vous devez réparer
par exemple un équipement qui qui est
défaillant ça peut être considéré comme
de l'entretien en fait voilà
pardon
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président merci de me laisser la
possibilité de nous laisser la
possibilité de nous exprimer au nom de
du groupe Suède sur notre vision
concernant la gestion durable de l'eau
Suez aujourd'hui c'est un groupe de
44000 collaborateurs dans le monde
et c'est vrai que le groupe a fait
l'objet d'une OPA en 2021 cela n'a
concerné que certaines activités
internationales et je pense que c'est
important de rappeler et Suez à
conserver l'intégralité de ses actifs
activités centre de recherche etc sur le
sur le territoire français alors je
pense monsieur c'est un sujet quand il y
a eu le rapprochement qui a été
important à souligner sur sur lesquels
voilà on avait travaillé encore un petit
peu dessus donc ça qu'on est voilà
sur les centres de recherche c'était une
question qui était vraiment posée sur la
table pour savoir de quelle manière les
compétences les centres de recherche
sont préservés et comment voilà les
centres de recherche qui étaient à
l'origine de Suez en particulier le
Circet qui est le le noyau dur de notre
centre de recherche sont aujourd'hui à
100% dans le groupe Suez donc les les
forces vives en matière de recherche et
développement sont restés au sein des
groupes Suez
alors je vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde est conscient que d'une
certaine manière la période de l'ofacile
elle est elle est derrière nous tout le
monde a pris conscience jusqu'au plus
haut sommet de l'État et dans ce
contexte on est heureux de pouvoir
partager autour de cette de cette table
ronde un certain nombre de choses que
plus de 150 ans d'expérience nous ont
apprises sur le territoire français ou à
l'international et quand je dis le
territoire français je parle de la
métropole évidemment mais je parle
également des territoires d'outre-mer
sur lesquels notre Groupe SUEZ est très
présent et on aura l'occasion si vous le
souhaitez de développer quelques-unes
des réalisations de notre groupe sur ces
territoires ultramarins alors le plan du
gouvernement puisque c'est c'est un
élément évidemment d'actualité il a
cette vertu de pousser à l'action sur
quantité de
piste de travail d'accord d'accord
d'accord d'accord d'accord parfait
Veolia c'est un tiers vous c'est à
combien de de distribution de l'eau
c'est à peu près 20%
sur cet aspect là si puisque la question
est posée j'en profite pour préciser
j'ai regardé dans le rapport du 6PA donc
les dernières rapports du 6 pains qui
indique la part délégation et l'appareil
des services d'eau et d'assainissement
en 2020 donc les dernières données à
disposition en 2020 la part délégué de
gestion délégué en eau potable c'est
57,6% et je me suis reporté aux années
pour lesquelles on dispose de donner du
spa donc en 2010 et en 2010 c'était 60%
vous voyez que en 10 ans il y a eu une
modification plutôt à la marge c'est
pour ça que je me permets monsieur le
Président de dire quand on dit qu'il y a
un glissement vers la gestion rigide bon
les chiffres ne confirment pas tout à
fait le rapporteur précisé qu'il y avait
un glissement vers la régie mais avec
aussi des nouveaux
des nouvelles coopérations aussi entre
entre vous
les collectivités
[Musique]
c'est plus une DSP pure et puis ou une
régie pure c'est ça peut être un hybride
on est d'accord oui absolument
voilà donc bah écoutez le alors on aura
l'occasion donc d'approfondir un certain
nombre de sujets évidemment notre groupe
a beaucoup d'expérience sur
tout un tas de sujets qui sont pointés
dans le plan et qui sont des des leviers
à mettre en oeuvre pour cette meilleure
gestion de l'eau donc la réduction des
fuites la réutilisation des objets
traitées la recherche maîtrisée des
aquifères sur lequel on a voilà on va y
venir on va parler du plan après et on
va parler des fuites
parfaitement donc voilà pour la
présentation la présentation et un peu
de la gestion délégué monsieur Bardy je
vous en prie
[Musique]
puisque on va dans l'ordre je vais finir
je vais essayer de finir beauté
nous avons une particularité au groupe
source et que nous sommes ce qu'on
appelle un pure player de l'eau
différence de mes voisins de table nous
sommes focalisés sur le cycle de l'eau
en détail et nous avons une approche
totalement différente de nos clients et
notamment de ce secteur en particulier
nous avons trois piliers de
développement actuellement qui sont
comment dire l'excellence pour
opérationnelle en France mieux couvrir
nos besoins dans tous les sens du terme
auprès de nos clients donc nous étions
d'être le plus proche possible au sein
des territoires nous avons en cours une
un développement international qui fait
de nous le troisième opérateur sur la
péninsule ibérique par exemple
aujourd'hui et nous avons un pied dans
tout ce qui est industriel de manière à
compléter notre gestion du cycle de
l'eau et intervenir auprès de tous les
acteurs
pour vous donner quelques chiffres clés
aujourd'hui nous enfin nous avons fini
2022 avec un chiffre d'affaires de 1,9
milliards d'euros ce qui signifie une
croissance de 30% par rapport à 2018
nous avons commencé ce nouveau cycle
nous sommes aujourd'hui 12000
collaborateurs nous étions que 7000 en
et nous intervenons auprès de 9500
collectivités locales les clients de
ciel pour à peu près 20 millions de
consommateurs juste pour bien comprendre
l'évolution s'est faite aussi par
l'intégration
d'autres d'autres sociétés
où nous avons un fort pôle industriel
aujourd'hui qui est
géré à travers une filiale néerlandaise
comme nous avons et nous sommes présents
dans à peu près on est implanté dans 20
pays et nous avons à peu près une
présence commerciale sur 100 un pays
dans le
sur terre ok donc
qu'est-ce que nous avons c'est que nous
avons une ambition c'est d'être champion
dans la transition hydrique et nous
avons une approche tout à fait
circulaire et intégré au niveau de
l'action du cycle de l'eau mais ça se
repercute également dans le modèle
d'entreprise nous avons aujourd'hui basé
l'intégralité de notre financement donc
notre dette est indexée sur des bons
durables avec des critères de
développement durable qui jugent la
performance financière d'entreprise vous
avez raison mais toute façon l'accès de
toute façon marché financier va être de
plus en plus est alloué aux engagements
des sociétés des entreprises qui sont
financement et avoir l'intégralité de
son financement là dessus c'est une
grande différence
et les taux d'intérêt qui nous sont
appliqués sont en fonction de nos
critères d'évolution ils sont jugés par
des parties tierces au niveau de la
réduction du prélèvement sur l'Union
naturel c'est nous avons des engagements
de réduction de notre prélèvement de la
ressource nous avons des engagements au
niveau de la décapantation de notre
industrie nous avons un engagement clair
pour passer à 100% d'énergie
renouvelable ne sont pas très loin et
puis nous avons un engagement par
exemple de équilibrer
la compréhension de nos équipes en
arrivant à la parité homme-femme c'est
des critères qui pèsent sur notre
financement si nous n'y arriverons pas
donc c'est un modèle d'entreprise tout à
fait la responsabilité sociétale non pas
uniquement social ce qui nous intéresse
particulièrement
effectivement il y a de souligner juste
sur le sujet que nous avions
évoqué par rapport au regroupement
comment travailler vous sur le partage
ou la complémentarité justement sur la
recherche et développement pour vous
mettre ces éléments en perspective un
des sujets que nous essayons de creuser
c'est de voir dans quelle mesure sur les
sujets qui touchent l'eau nous pouvons
améliorer les process de recherche et de
développement mais aussi appliqués de
faire en sorte de créer les conditions
d'une acceptabilité économique par
rapport à l'ensemble des usages pour
qu'en même temps il y ait une
appropriation de ces évolutions
technologiques alors bien sûr elles sont
pour vous au sein même de vos process
mais vous imaginez que sur toutes les
autres pratiques irrigations etc c'est
une question forte de savoir comment la
recherche est développement se met en
oeuvre comment aller financée
aujourd'hui et comment on la rend
accessible par rapport aux usagers alors
la question d'abord par rapport à vous
c'est est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
vraiment sur des principes de
coopération toujours en silo pour faire
court
[Musique]
l'innovation dans notre domaine qui est
extrêmement et c'est normal structuré
par la comment je dirais la chose
publique
y compris dans le niveau des décisions
opérationnelles
ça commence avec les normes
qu'on ne peut absolument pas remplacer
les normes pour la qualité de l'eau
potable les normes pour la qualité de
l'eau pour irriguer les cultures et
toutes les normes d'une façon générale
ainsi que les normes sur la façon de
gérer les processus
c'est par rapport à ça qu'on s'organise
et qu'on réagit dans notre qualité donc
de l'entreprise de service
après ça le sur la façon dont on
travaille je dirais on a des centres de
recherche
sous contrôle de mes confrères on a des
centres de recherche mais qui sont pas
des vases clos c'est des entités qui
sont ouvertes on fait beaucoup appel
entre guillemets au-delà de la
littérature mais on fait beaucoup appel
à ce qu'on appellerait
l'innovation ouverte pour ne pas prendre
l'anglicisme
ce qui veut dire que on a je dirais ces
organisations qui ont en charge de
développer effectivement les solutions
opérationnelles encore une fois dans un
contexte extrêmement ouvert et en
faisant appel aux compétences aux
productions ou qu'elles soient y compris
en France évidemment avec un certain
nombre de partenariats donc à votre
réponse monsieur le rapporteur à votre
question monsieur le rapporteur je
dirais on a une réponse qui est un petit
peu hybride en tout cas de notre point
de vue on dit mais on pourra pas être en
silo c'est pas possible c'est pas c'est
pas quelques centaines de personnes
fût-elle remarquables qu'on peut qui
pourront développer les solutions de
demain c'est un système qui est beaucoup
plus inclusif que ça même si une filet
le pour ce qui revient de financement de
la recherche mais évidemment c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait sur nos fonds
propres et avec toutes les je dirais les
implications en matière de gestion
juste pour approfondir vous dites son
propre aujourd'hui il y a de plus en
plus appels à projets avec des
passerelles entre le monde industriel le
monde de la recherche le monde
universitaire je suppose que doit aussi
en avoir il y a aussi des appels à
projets européens à l'heure actuelle
mais
réaction
oui bien sûr
à la fois la mutualisation et la
transversalité des travaux de travaux de
recherche et en même temps sur la
relation avec les scientifiques et oui
alors nous effectivement nous nous
sommes présents sur un certain nombre de
projets sur appel à projet
à toute échelle appelée
des agences de l'eau on s'implique on
s'implique là-dedans on pourra
d'ailleurs vous faire parvenir si vous
souhaitez des listes d'un certain nombre
de projets avec plaisir participatif
comme ça sur lesquels sur lesquels on
travaille
on est donc effectivement une recherche
effectivement je souscris à ce que
disait monsieur de Veolia de recherche
ouverte avec des dimensions qui sont à
la fois techniques mais aussi des
dimensions sociétales on a par exemple
chez Suez un centre de recherche qui
s'appelle le lire qui est situé à
Bordeaux qui a tout un tout un volet
société de d'analyser on pourra aussi
vous faire parvenir les
programmes de recherche sur lequel il
travaille
le lire vous connaissez vous connaissez
donc bien voilà toutes les conséquences
des des innovations sur les
comportements parce que on est on est
sur un métier qui ne peut pas rester un
métier d'expert et sur un métier qui
doit qui ne peut être couvert avec mais
en général la société donc on prend bien
cette dimension là en compte merci
Monsieur Bardy peut-être une réaction je
dirais que nous avons tous de relation
avec le monde académique avec le monde
industriel et nous explorons diverses
voies et nous avons des voies établies
pour tout ce qui est recherchés
d'un point de vue très élargie je
voudrais juste rappeler que nous sommes
quand même trop groupe concurrents et
nous ne faisons pas de la recherche en
commun et nous partage pas nos
recherches selon des démarches tout à
fait différentes avec des axes peut-être
différents par moments ça ne choquera
personne par contre au niveau de des
solutions que chaque groupe met en place
chaque groupe mettre en place une
solution adéquate pour le problème que
peut lui poser
oui ça reste quand même une question
parce que quand il y a eu rapprochement
qui s'est fait on imagine qu'à un moment
donné il y a aussi du transfert de
connaissances et de compétences même
s'il y a une notion de concurrence qui
reste établie c'est pas
c'est un sujet sur lequel on avait
travaillé en effet on nous avait dit
il y avait les deux visions où il y
avait la vision qu'il fallait garder
vraiment de pôles de recherche parce que
vous aviez des typologies de recherche
des méthodes de recherche différentes et
que c'était peut-être plus efficace et
puis il y a aussi une vision qu'on a
essayé de nous vendre c'est que si on a
un seul grand groupe la recherche par
effet champion mondial un champion
mondial voilà c'est ce qu'on a essayé de
nous vendre la recherche serait plus
efficace donc j'ai bien entendu tout à
l'heure que vous nous avez dit que vos
forces vives étaient préservées et je
dois vous dire que nous c'était une
vraie inquiétude quand même votre
capacité à terme à rester efficient dans
la recherche donc est-ce que vous pouvez
vraiment nous confirmer que vous avez
préservé ces capacités de recherche en
tant que voilà entité plus restreint
aujourd'hui je vous le confirme
absolument absolument comme je vous
disais le Circé notre Centre
international de recherche
l'environnement qui existe depuis
quelques décennies mais qui s'est
beaucoup qui a beaucoup évolué ces
moderniser au cours des années le Circé
avec l'intégralité de ces de ces
chercheurs de ces techniciens est restés
au sein du groupe Suez et c'est ainsi
que le lire monsieur le rapporteur en
tant que Girondins connaît bien ce
centre de recherche ainsi que d'autres
émanations qui dépendent de direction de
la de l'innovation tout ça est bien
resté au sein du groupe au sein au sein
du groupe Suez et nous permet
aujourd'hui de travailler sur des
programmes de recherche et d'ailleurs
il est très clair que dans la nouvelle
stratégie du groupe porté par la
nouvelle direction en place la
différenciation technique et par
l'innovation est une est une une
priorité stratégique donc je vous le
confirme
d'ailleurs je peux me permettre
madame messieurs de vous inviter à venir
visiter notre Centre de recherche le
Circet vous y serez très bien reçu et
vous pouvez voir tous les sujets sur les
campagnes qui sont très qui sont très
variés qui sont qui sont vraiment très
variés sur dans le domaine alors de
l'eau puisque c'est ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui mais également
dans le domaine de des déchets peut-être
dire en quoi les perspectives de
recherche peuvent répondre aux enjeux
auxquels nous nous faisons face
aujourd'hui
j'ai combien de temps pour répondre
cette question non
je citais enfin
quand on regarde sur chacun des thèmes
qui sont abordés dans le plan haut
sur chacun des thèmes on se dit là il y
a des axes de recherche qui peuvent
permettre de s'améliorer on parlait par
exemple le fuites la réduction des
fuites c'est c'est
pas mais pour le coup comme Florence
vient d'ouvrir la question à ce niveau
là autant il y a les directement pour
aborder notamment les aspects peut-être
les plus prépondérants aujourd'hui sur
pour le coup quand on parle de la
recherche et de la technologie si
effectivement les fuites les nouveaux
polluants donc ça ça nous intéresse
également peut-être que même sur les
captages peut-être qu'il y a aussi des
nouvelles approches aussi mais au moins
sur les voilà les fluides et puis les
pollutions sur les fuites donc et le on
va dire le la performance des réseaux de
distribution d'eau
il est clair que on
heureusement la seule unique réponse
elle n'est pas de remplacer les tuyaux
de mettre des tuyaux heureusement comme
toute équipement il vaut mieux réparer
avant de avant de remplacer et là on est
je vais dire principalement sur on va
dire trois axes dans les grandes lignes
sur l'amélioration de la performance des
réseaux un axe qui consiste à une
meilleure maîtrise
du réseau c'est à dire être en capacité
de repérer les fuites le plus rapidement
possible pour pouvoir les réparer le
plus rapidement possible la difficulté
des fuites dans les réseaux d'eau c'est
qu'on les voit pas souvent ça s'infiltre
dans le sol donc l'enjeu c'est d'être
capable de les de les identifier
rapidement et d'aller rapidement envoyer
et là-dessus le numérique a été un
apport considérable depuis ces dernières
années d'ailleurs je tiens quand même à
dire aujourd'hui on dit en moyenne à peu
près 20% de perte 80% de rendement si on
se reporte peut-être 20 ans en arrière
on était plutôt à 70,30 donc il faut
quand même noter
il reste du chemin à faire certes mais
il faut noter le chemin qui a été fait
et en partie la progression était faite
et en partie grâce au numérique aux
réseaux intelligent qui permettent
d'être beaucoup plus efficient dans la
dans ce recherche détection de fuite le
deuxième axe sur lequel il y a aussi
beaucoup de progrès toutes la gestion de
la pression la pression dans la région
ça fatigue les réseaux ça les fait
casser et on a des des dispositifs de
plus en plus performants pour gérer la
pression pour mieux la maîtriser pour
maîtriser les je pars en train les
tailles trop techniques mais pour
maîtriser par exemple les les accouts de
pression ou les ce qu'on appelle les
coups de bélier qui fatigue ça il faut
être en mesure de les détecter d'en
trouver l'origine pour corriger cette
cette origine améliorer ça et puis la
troisième sujet quand même malgré tout
quand on est sur un réseau qui se met à
casser beaucoup à un moment donné se
pose la question de son remplacement et
là il y a tout un enjeu parce que ça
coûte très cher de remplacer des tuyaux
il y a tout un enjeu qui consiste à dire
où est-ce qu'on va les mettre l'argent
le plus intelligemment possible pour que
la réparation soit vraiment là où c'est
nécessaire et là il y a tout aussi des
sujets sur lesquels il y a eu beaucoup
de progrès il y en a encore sur les
diagnostics qu'on appelle l'analyse
patrimoniale
comprendre les les risques de
défaillance etc donc tout ça fait que et
ça nous amène à beaucoup de de comment
dirais-je d'innovation de travail
d'amélioration qui vont dans le sens
d'une meilleure
maîtrise et gestion des réseaux
la parole oui peut-être monsieur Barbier
monsieur
est-ce que vous avez aidé aujourd'hui du
niveau de connaissance patrimoniale de
chaque structure parfois c'est vrai que
on a des raisons qui ont été construits
dans les années 50 pas toujours sous
même bien avant mais souvent
sur des terrains privés on n'a pas
toujours une bonne connaissance de
patrimonial du réseau donc comment
parce que comme la question était assez
ouverte sur plusieurs aspects que tu as
lancé la première vous laissez le soin
de répondre après monsieur Brunet si
vous voulez apporter des compléments et
puis on va aller un peu plus loin sur la
connaissance du patrimoine est-ce qu'il
y a déjà des premiers niveaux de
réaction par rapport à monsieur Brunet
qui s'est exprimait monsieur
ce qui a été dit j'ai pas de pas de
commentaire particulier effectivement je
pense qu'il faut différencier la remise
à niveau patrimonial de l'exploitation
courante
et je dirais que les principes sur tout
ce qui est on va dire rendement de
réseau
on va on va y venir prendre plutôt si on
devait simplifier dire quand c'est un
très mauvais état il vaut mieux réparer
quand c'est globalement en bon état il
vaut mieux faire de ce qu'on appelle de
la recherche de fuite active donc quand
on a des réseaux qui sont très
défaillants
l'instrumentation la recherche le
diagnostic et leur activité
opérationnelle pour aller traquer les
fuites mais il y a on parle du réseau
mais un autre sujet c'est le réseau
continue chez le particulier et donc et
ensuite dans les fuites il y a des
fuites après compteur donc là il y a
comme c'est pas toujours évident de
repérer ces fuites là la technologie
permet quand même de faire des progrès
en particulier une technologie que dans
notre métier on appelle le téléréalité
ou les télés les compteurs intelligents
qui qui permettent de détecter les
écoulements en normal quand ils sont
chez le particulier qui les détecte pas
ça ça permet d'économiser quand même
aujourd'hui le parti les relevés en
France et
on n'est pas en 100% de télé relevé donc
de compteurs intelligent en France
c'est un point qui a été qui a été
souligné dans le plan dans le plan du
président dans le plan o donc la télé
est un élément important pour lutter
contre les fuites chez le particulier
et aujourd'hui rien que moi je peux vous
dire pour pour notre groupe pour Veolia
l'année dernière sur on a identifié
environ
60 plus de 70 000 fuites après compteur
qui représente plusieurs millions de
mètres cubes donc l'économiser sur les
consommations pardon vous voulez voyez
sur les consommateurs
c'est une chasse d'eau qui fuit vous
voyez déployer des consoles non mais par
contre c'est repéré la fuite parce que
nous ce qu'on mesure on va dire c'est un
relevé de compteur quand il est pas
intelligent voilà donc vous passez tous
les tous les ans peut-être faire une
fuite continue de 1 ou 2 litres ou trois
litres ou 4 litres ou 10 litres vous la
voyez pas par contre le télévé comme ça
suit entre guillemets en continu vous
voyez des choses anormales on est bien
d'accord dans tout l'intérêt c'est
d'arriver à développer les relevés les
compteurs intelligents et qui permettent
de développer
la technologie existe c'est les c'est
les déployer la technologie existe elle
est fiable elle est maîtrisait un coup
comme notre
participer d'un programme d'action
d'accélération
puisque vous devez partager à peu près
le même niveau d'analyse et de
diagnostic ça veut dire que après
compteur vous estimez à combien de
pourcentage de perte
ça doit être connu à peu près ce chiffre
là oui les études qu'on a faites nous on
estime à peu près à 8%
[Musique]
8%es mais je souhaite juste souligner
que le souci que vous évoquez par
rapport à la mise en commun des centres
de recherche était dans le cadre d'une
fusion acquisition et
un carvarottes des deux voisins donc je
ne suis pas concerné par ce sujet par
contre on a parlé innovation pour
répondre à certains à certains problèmes
donc moi
oui nous avons des approches parfois
similaires parfois un peu différentes je
pense que on parle de patrimoine on
parle également de patrimoine de la
donnée de la donnée digitale de la
donnée électronique qui va nous
permettre de faire beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui nous avons devenir un centre
de recherche dans le domaine du digital
avec un certain nombre d'ingénierie mis
en place et aujourd'hui
nous travaillons sur les modèles
prédictifs non seulement pour intervenir
non seulement pour suivre mais pour
anticiper et essayer de gérer au mieux
tous ces aspects de de
sobriété au global du cycle de l'eau
j'irai plus loin et Monsieur le
vice-président j'espère que comme
Monsieur aura visité le Centre de
recherche en Gironde vous aurez
l'occasion de visiter ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui dans la médecin
Brieuc où nous interrons pas seulement à
une usine lorsqu'on l'a construit mais
on gère également au mieux avec des
études très spécifiques la gestion de la
ressource en amont et l'usine n'est plus
une usine qui est au sein d'une clôture
c'est un élément d'équipement et d'un
système d'eau qui va se mettre en
combinaison avec la ressource son
comportement et son évolution dans le
temps mais également avec les
utilisateurs et Laval et ça ça fait
qu'aujourd'hui
on a vu plus on avait plus en silo
l'usine d'eau potable de celle qui est
un peu flagrant exactement
exactement donc il faut considérer ces
systèmes aujourd'hui plus comme des
éléments en silo comme vous disiez mais
plutôt des éléments intégrés qui vont
faire vivre et qu'une certaine vie au
sein du système et qui vont faire vont
voler de manière différente il faut que
tout puisse adapter en plus j'ai rien le
maximum de prévisions
disponible monsieur Bardy par rapport à
ça mais la question s'adresse bien sûr à
l'ensemble de nos interlocuteurs
aujourd'hui on voit bien les éléments
qui peuvent permettre d'améliorer les
process à différents niveaux la question
de savoir comment elle se cristallise
aujourd'hui
dans toutes les délégations si je
reformule les choses autrement
à chaque fois que vous faites des un
travail particulier même de changement
de compteur etc ça induit une charge
supplémentaire au niveau du contrat on
est bien d'accord et de la délégation
donc entre les ambitions qu'on peut
avoir et les objectifs qu'on peut avoir
et de quelle manière ensuite ils sont
traduits dans les contrats et dans les
délégations il peut y avoir une marge
remplacement de compteur etc donc ce
dialogue de toute façon avec avec les
collectivités
est-ce qu'il est clairement écrit au
niveau des contrats dans les objectifs
de performance au niveau des réseaux
est-ce que cette écriture aujourd'hui
est suffisamment satisfaisante est-ce
que elle ne pose pas des questions
justement simplement pour accompagner la
nécessaire monter en puissance de la
qualité de la performance des réseaux
[Musique]
je me permets de répondre cette fois-ci
en premier je on renvoie toujours à
au choix qui est le premier qui est
celui le choix politique de la décision
de comment va gérer le système de l'eau
et dans quelle mesure on va mettre des
des particularités contractuelles dans
la gestion du service de l'eau
évidemment d'un territoire à un autre
nous avons des différences déjà de
territoire mais également d'approches du
du système et d'approche de la gestion
d'un patrimoniale la gestion
contractuelle du service
ce qui peut être sûr c'est que
il y a quand même des clauses de
revoyure avec des contraintes
contractuelles dans les dans les dans
les différents contrats et que si on est
sur une base de de suivi transparent
avec un certain nombre de paramètres de
suivi qui puissent donner par exemple
tous ces toutes les données dont vous
parlez permettant de donner
à la à l'autorité
qui coordonne le service de l'eau les
orientations qu'elle veut et pouvoir
contrôler au bout d'un certain temps au
bout d'un certain délai je pense que le
ça peut être fait ça peut monsieur mardi
mais là je pousse le train
involontairement du jeu c'est de faire
sortir un peu les sujets et puis de
regarder comment les discute et ce sur
quoi nous on peut éventuellement faire
avancer mais du coup si on avait une
forme de norme plus contraignante
aujourd'hui dans l'élaboration des
contraintes en termes d'objectifs et de
performances on aurait sans doute un
process d'accompagnement et de mise en
œuvre qui serait accélérée et donc c'est
aussi la question de fond moins vous
avez de contrats qui sont contraignants
moi vous êtes invité à le faire pour
dire les choses comme elles sont et
c'est une réalité plus vous avez des
contrats qui sont contraignants et
partagés en termes de recherche
d'objectifs et de performance plus il y
a forcément un moment donné la nécessité
de mettre sur table mais ça veut dire un
dialogue ensuite de gestion puisque
derrière il y aura forcément des
compétences du temps de l'énergie et de
l'argent on est bien d'accord mais la
question de l'évolution qualitative des
contrats elle est majeure
voilà donc je vous demande de réagir un
peu là dessus et je pense qu'au bout du
bout vous avez intérêt
pardon je finis juste ma réponse puisque
j'en ai parlé lors de l'introduction je
vous ai mentionné le fait que la
structuration de notre dette était faite
sur des critères
RSE et que dans ces lavation de ces
critères nous avions la diminution
obligatoire des prélèvements de la
ressource dans nos contrats donc
évidemment nous travaillons déjà sur la
diminution de des fuites en diminution
quantitative et qualitative des
prélèvements et cela nous oblige à aller
dans ce sens là pour nous aujourd'hui
groupe sort c'est un argument de vente
demain c'est lorsque vous dites ce sera
juste une obligation contractuelle
laissez-nous un peu d'avance on souhaite
continuer comme ça bien ressortir la
façon de vous présenter les choses je
vous en prie
alors sur les les obligations
contractuelles et les et les
objectifs qui peut y avoir dans les
contrats de délégation c'est à celui que
je me permets sur le reportage j'étais
en post-à-bordeaux
en tant que que délégataire pour la ce
qui s'appelait à l'époque la Communauté
urbaine de Bordeaux dans les années 2000
et
pardon c'est qui a basculé enregistre
bon on est forcé de le constater
et à l'époque avec la Communauté urbaine
de Bordeaux je pense qu'on avait été
assez innovant parce que dans les dans
les renouvelles dans les renégociations
quinquennales avaient été introduit et
je pense que c'était un peu pionnier à
l'époque ça commençait justement des
indicateurs de performance et je pense
que depuis alors ça a été fait
évidemment par tout ailleurs on n'est
pas les seuls mais depuis ça c'est
beaucoup ça s'est beaucoup intégré dans
les contrôles je pense qu'aujourd'hui un
contrat de délégation il y a pas un
contrat de délégation dans lesquels il y
a pas d'obligation de performance
d'amélioration de réseau par rapport à
ça quand on ne regarde un peu plus près
vous avez pas forcément une une énorme
aussi claire que ça sur
normé au sens que on retrouve une
famille et une batterie d'indicateurs
qui soient réellement partagée sur
l'ensemble des contrats avec des
objectifs qui sont pour dire globaux et
assignés au niveau national on en est
pas là encore aujourd'hui le travail au
niveau des au niveau des indicateurs
c'est un travail aussi parce que en
effet
a été fait le constat il y a une
vingtaine d'années que
vous avez tout à fait raison chacun
calculer un peu les indicateurs comme il
voulait et bon il y a un gros travail
qui a été fait de
de mise aux normes on va dire
d'indicateurs de définition
d'indicateurs
tout à l'heure je citer le 6 PA qui
permet d'avoir une base sur lequel il y
a pour chacun navigateur la manière dont
c'est calculé etc d'ailleurs c'est en
cours d'être de révision actuellement
parce que parce que bon bah ça évolue on
s'aperçoit que faut faire évoluer tout
ça c'est un cours de réunion je pense
que la manière de calculer les
indicateurs d'une part et d'autre part
de plus en plus l'accès qui est donné à
nos clients aux données l'exploitation
via nos systèmes experts Viano nos
différents systèmes via les portails
numériques que l'on peut avoir
permettent aussi de plus en plus de
d'aller vers cette transparence qui est
nécessité par tout le monde et juste
pour conclure nous on est absolument
demandeur à ce qui est des objectifs de
performance parce que finalement nos
entreprises j'imagine que mes
concurrents pensent la même chose nos
entreprises ce qui nous permet de nous
différencier c'est quand on peut
apporter du savoir-faire
de de la maîtrise qui puisse être
ensuite être mesuré
et d'ailleurs s'il faut se comparer au
régime on aimerait pouvoir se comparer
aussi dans les performances techniques
de nos services bien sûr une réaction
peut-être sur le sujet qualité des
contrats objectifs en fait oui
l'objectif effectivement je voulais
prendre un petit peu de temps pour
discuter de ça
parce que je partage certains des
éléments qui ont été évoqués nous on est
une entreprise privée donc on est drivés
par la performance c'est ça qui nous
fait nous lever tous les matins
et la satisfaction de nos clients mais
aujourd'hui je dirais vous parler de de
normes ou de batterie d'indicateurs
normé
aujourd'hui on ce qu'on peut constater
c'est effectivement la d'une façon
générale la réglementation fait évoluer
le métier
tu l'évoquais tout à l'heure Dominique
les normes les normes sanitaires les
normes environnementales font évoluer le
métier effectivement c'est en poussant
les barrières le plus loin possible les
objectifs le moins possible que nous en
innovante en charge des solutions et on
améliore le métier mais je pense que la
question des indicateurs c'est c'est
pourquoi faire et aujourd'hui le défi
majeur et un enjeu sanitaire il rend de
l'eau mais un enjeu majeur qui est la
vitesse à laquelle le dérèglement
climatique bouleverse le cycle de l'eau
des éléments qu'on évoqués comme comme
les fuites en font partie mais et donc
ça c'est un sujet local donc le projet
il doit s'inscrire localement
est-ce qu'on va pas porter les mêmes
solutions si on est en bord de mer si on
est dans le Sud-Ouest si on est dans une
planète agricole ou si on est dans une
zone touristique ou une zone
industrielle donc le je pense que on
peut regarder effectivement je pense
c'est une piste intéressante
effectivement de travailler à cette
normalisation des indicateurs
nous avons déjà dans nos contrats des
batteries d'indicateurs aujourd'hui à
des contrats où on revoit
trimestriellement plusieurs centaines
d'indicateurs sur lesquels nous sommes
pénalisés si nous les atteignons pas
donc mais le point je voulais souligner
c'est
l'alignement l'alignement entre
l'intention de la maîtrise d'ouvrage
public de la collectivité sans
diagnostic territorial
le fait
on va dire nouveau parce qu'on l'a vécu
récemment l'été dernier et probablement
votre vie quelque chose d'assez
similaire cet été que le dérèglement
climatique
bouleverse le cycle de l'eau et que nos
infrastructures et nos services d'eau
l'élasticité est quand même
je pense relativement faible en fait par
rapport à ces contraintes climatiques
qui vont modifier le cycle de l'eau et
donc comment on construit un projet de
résilience et d'adaptation
donc effectivement ensuite trouver la
meilleure façon d'aligner
les objectifs
et les besoins de la collectivité avec
l'offre de ces de ces prestataires donc
l'indicateur je pense que c'est bien
c'est important il faut qu'il soit clair
objectif et qu'il soit pas discuté voilà
éternellement par les par les uns et par
les autres mais la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire et
aujourd'hui la priorité pour les
services d'eau en France c'est
l'adaptation de ces services au
bouleversement
dérèglement climatique et donc qui
modifie quand même dramatiquement
l'accès à la ressource en quantité et en
qualité et on est d'accord on va
rebondir sur la qualité tout à l'heure
on va parce que c'est un sujet qu'on
peut pas passer à côté juste peut-être
pour terminer un peu cette approche là
qui me paraît intéressant sur
l'évolution contractuelle à ce niveau là
un des éléments sur lequel on travaille
en l'occurrence c'est un
approfondissement de la connaissance
aussi par bassin versant en termes de
quantité et de consommation de telle
manière qu'on rapproche véritablement
les enjeux et qu'on essaye d'avoir une
gouvernance qui ensuite par susbilarité
soit percolé si vous me permettez
l'expression dans tous les niveaux en
termes de subsidiarité et donc de
partager cette gouvernance à l'échelle
du bassin mais ensuite jusqu'à l'échelle
d'une métropole d'une agglo et c'est
logique puisque les réglementations des
agences de l'eau vont aussi s'adapter ou
doivent s'adapter sur justement ces
enjeux de cette gouvernance par bassin
donc là dessus pas de souci je pense
qu'on est bien d'accord et on est bien
calé
après on voit bien que en plus les
sujets que vous abordez ils sont
aujourd'hui dans une approche qui
dépasse même l'approche contractuelle
simplement avec les collectivités qui
sont vos clients c'est que les
collectivités dont développé vont devoir
développer des solidarités entre elles
et ça pose la question aujourd'hui des
interconnexions des réseaux donc ça
c'est un sujet majeur pour arriver à
sécuriser aussi la ressource et voir
comment on s'organise donc on est bien
sur des sujets qui sont en train de
s'ouvrir par rapport à l'adaptation sur
la nécessité d'interconnecter
effectivement les réseaux d'ouvrir le
dialogue territorial à ce niveau-là et
de trouver des modalités de gestion de
la ressource qui nécessairement devront
s'appuyer aussi sur des coopérations
territoriales l'exemple de Bordeaux
c'est évident je suis en captant du
Médoc parce que ça je n'approfonde on
peut plus tirer dessus donc vous voyez
le sujet et ce sujet là il est pas
simple il pose aussi des coopérations
territoriales pour arriver à sécuriser
le dispositif pour clôturer peut-être
juste une réaction sur ce que je viens
de dire
je pense que moi je partage sur le
réseau puisqu'on avait la thématique des
filles du réseau le rendement de réseau
effectivement des éléments dans le
cocktail de solutions qui peut être
proposée pour s'adapter aux conséquences
du dérèglement climatique sur le cycle
de l'eau l'interconnexion
l'interconnexion fait partie donc
et aujourd'hui les réseaux on le sait
sont pas sont pas tous maillés l'eau de
l'eau du Nord descend pas dans le sud
c'est c'est pas non plus l'objectif mais
effectivement mobiliser des ressources
rééquilibrée j'allais dire alternative
peut-être penser aussi au dehors en
dehors de la boîte c'est-à-dire regarder
un petit peu plus loin c'est un enjeu
ensuite qui nous dépasse largement en
tout cas oui mais nous en tant que en
tant qu'opérateur mais oui mais oui mais
parce que les principes à la fois
d'interconnexion de coopération etc Il
vous concerne aussi un peu alors moi
j'ai une vision beaucoup plus peut-être
simpliste mais nous sommes en
prestataire de service donc à partir du
moment où ce qui l'objectif est défini
nous on s'adapte en fournit l'offre de
service
comme je disais sur l'interconnexion
c'est une décision de coopération entre
territoire et nous nous sommes dans la
partie des fournisseurs de services et
pas dans la partie de la décision
politique qui est qui est du ressort la
maîtrise d'ouvrage l'organisation du
service et donc réellement dans la main
de de l'autorité de l'autorité publique
l'interconnexion effectivement et donc
amène la notion de solidarité entre les
territoires sur sur la ressource à nous
fait partie fait partie des solutions
qu'il faut parfois examiner sur un
territoire où il y a moins de ressources
de ressources disponibles
on en parlera probablement on entend la
traduction l'interconnexion elle se fait
souvent au niveau au départemental
départemental de l'eau et on a on a
réussi à faire Yannick avec Yannick
votre reine sénateur d'ailleurs une
interconnexion de de on est complètement
interconnecté dans le département de
l'est à l'ouest du département on peut
c'est très variable en fait il y a des
départements voilà ou c'est vraiment des
intercommandes
voilà donc là ça dépend ça dépend
complètement on aurait besoin d'ailleurs
de connaître mieux pour aujourd'hui où
on en est des intérêts des réseaux
interconnectés
sur la télé relève avoir l'état
aujourd'hui pourcentage en télérélève à
mon avis dans les territoires urbains
quels sont les freins en tes territoire
ruraux parce que il y en a quand même
les questions d'émissions et sur quel si
comme voilà sur quelle partie à quel
pourcentage du territoire à votre avis
peut-on couvrir en télérélève et
forcément si on va faire un changement
de relève mettons d'une relève manuelle
en télé relève pour vous j'imagine que
ça signifie un avenant au contrat
sur lequel qu'elle pourrait être
techniquement c'est possible de le faire
sur tous les compteurs donc 100% voilà
c'est technique c'est techniquement
faisable
pense à dépendre entre les différentes
les différentes collectivités mais
pour vous donner les chiffres précis
mais le téléréalité donc c'est le qui
est pas la radio relevé donc le thé
relevé automatique entre guillemets en
continu
lors de grandeur que j'ai c'est
entre 20 et 30%
[Musique]
c'est finalement aller chercher des
ressources ailleurs il y a des
ressources qui sont en général tout le
temps présentes sur un territoire c'est
les eaux usées
il y a pas de souci
[Musique]
je mets juste de côté pour qu'on ait une
réaction générale sur la route puisque
c'est un sujet qui est mis sur table
déjà et juste pour avoir aussi vos
commentaires juste sur ce cycle là
d'interrogation est-ce qu'il y a des
commentaires supplémentaires monsieur
Brunet vous souhaitez intervenir juste
un commentaire alors nous on est on est
de l'ordre de 40% de compteurs équipés
en télé enlève sur le territoire un
commentaire c'est que
enfin plus plus ça va plus on se dit la
gestion d'une ressource aussi qui
devient aussi enfin rare
à partir d'un du l'ancien compteur
mécanique qu'on relève une fois par an
on dit ça n'est plus ça n'est plus
d'actualité par rapport aux enjeux qui
sont devant nous quand on relève une
fois par an on sait pas quand tu as eu
lieu la consommation quel type quel
profil etc donc là dessus dit vraiment
le compteur intelligent le compteur
fournisseur d'information faut vraiment
aller vers ça si on veut avoir une
gestion fine de de voilà et puis juste
question fine de de voilà et puis juste
je me permets de petits commentaires sur
l'interconnexion
j'ai alors bien sûr alors les
interconnexions entre collectivités
c'est évidemment
à mettre en place ça ça
moi j'ai en tête un cas particulier tout
à l'heure je parlais d'outre-mer
il faut évidemment que les collectivités
qui vont s'interconnecter et l'une à
portée de l'eau à l'autre il faut
évidemment qu'il y ait des engagements
d'un bon usage de l'eau
et donc un engagement si la collectivité
a apporte de l'eau à la collectivité B
faut pas que ce soit pour alimenter les
fuites de la collectivité mais donc là
il y a une correspondabilité évidemment
à partager
alors une rapide d'enfance pour Madame
lors de grandeur chez nous c'est de
l'ordre de 10%. donc c'est encore plus
faible vous voyez qu'on a du chemin
parcourir
mais justement moi je vais rebondir par
rapport aux propos que vous avez tenu et
aux échanges qui ont eu lieu parce que
j'ai bien noté votre
si c'est pas votre souhait en tout cas
la possibilité de dessiner une autre un
autre environnement contractuel avec
peut-être un peu plus d'obligations
des obligations peut-être plus
rigoureuses en termes de définition et
voir même normatif on a parlé de normer
des des indicateurs mais les normés
c'est pas seulement
définir un indicateur mais c'est
également normé la méthode de mesure je
vais donner un exemple
bête et méchant mais quelque part on va
dire c'est 10 km/h mais peut-être que
l'heure chez moi c'est 59 minutes et
chez ma voisin c'est 61 et 65 on en est
là dans le domaine scientifique de ces
paramètres là éventuellement je dirais
c'est bien
cet esprit des rigueur que l'on va
injecter dans l'établissement des
contraintes
j'ai entendu également parler d'urgence
liée aux efforts que l'on nous avons
développé face aux défis climatiques que
nous rencontrons mais
augmenter la contrainte bien
répondre à l'urgence bien mais il va
peut-être falloir libérer quelques
contraintes autres du style normatif ou
procédural qui pour nous permettre de
répondre à vos souhaits et aller dans le
rythme que nous souhaitons vous aurez
l'occasion des exprimer on est très
ouvert sur vos propositions dans la
matière peut-être ouvrir un autre cycle
de questions là on était sur cette
approche à la fois de réseau de qualité
de contrats
revenir sur la notion de dépollution
l'évolution à ce niveau là en
l'occurrence aussi des normes des
spectres qui commencent à être un peu
plus large mais on s'est aperçu que les
politiques ARS c'était assez
différenciés malgré tout au niveau des
territoires sur ce qu'on observait il y
a
60 échantillons ou 60 molécules qui sont
à peu près communes au niveau national
mais après il y a des différenciations
territoriales qui sont relativement
importantes donc sur ces sujets là
également
quels sont les messages que vous
souhaiteriez nous faire passer
comment vous voyez également
cet aspect des pollutions des nouvelles
pollutions émergentes aujourd'hui et qui
font partie aussi de l'actualité
comment vous voyez ce sujet Quels sont
si vos stratégies alors peut-être que on
renverse monsieur Bardy vous reprenez la
parole et puis on va là on va la
descendre
[Musique]
nous ne pouvons pas
nous dissocier nous venons de l'aborder
d'ailleurs le fait qu'il y a une quand
même spécificité territoriale donc nous
allons rencontrer de par la nature du
relief de par la nature du climat local
de par la nature des ressources des
configurations différentes
chez sors nous sommes bien évidemment
habitués à répondre à ces sollicitations
aux différentes contraintes et il y a
pas forcément non plus
disons de divergences extrêmes entre les
situations vous parlez d'une soixantaine
de composants faut savoir faut savoir
que parmi ces composants est plutôt des
familles et lorsqu'on traite une famille
en tête même des composants donc on
n'est pas aujourd'hui l'existence mais
qu'on va découvrir demain et en fait ils
sont associés à une famille ce sera
traité donc
par contre
il faut simplifier cette gestion locale
et j'ai simplifié la gestion locale
c'est ne pas pousser trop dans cette
spécificité locale en disant que c'est
ça qui va compliquer le sujet il faut
plutôt aujourd'hui vous parler d'une
soixantaine je dirais on fixe déjà cette
soixantaine de substances et on les
traite les 60
ne perdons pas de temps à attendre que
20 supplémentaires qui apparaissent oui
mais monsieur Bardy on crée un débat un
peu interactif si vous me le permettez
mais qui décide nous aujourd'hui sur les
auditions qu'on a que nous avons faites
c'est la RS qui décide et on a
l'impression qu'elle est toute seule on
se trompe qui décide véritablement de la
famille des molécules qui sont observées
au niveau des territoires
si vous pouvez nous apporter un peu
cette information on est très très
preneur parce qu'on a du mal à situer
qui décide véritablement enfin on sait
qu'il y en a au moins un c'est l'ARS
mais on sait pas avec qui
[Musique]
nous avons déjà quand même une un
système de décision qui est géré au
niveau européen
après il y a une une retranscription de
la décision et du consensus européen au
niveau national OK et après vous avez un
dispatching au niveau des ARS qui fait
que dont on est l'autonomie de décision
et l'autonomie de gestion des dossiers
qui est tout à fait local
exactement je vais jusqu'au bout
excusez-moi de la question locale mais
c'est qui au niveau local parce que si
c'est simplement le directeur de l'ARS
qui décide tout seul ça pose une petite
question quand même
enfin moi ça m'interpelle ça
m'interpelle parce que pourquoi lui il
va décider de telle spectre par rapport
à un autre quelle est la négociation la
discussion le partage des enjeux partage
des enjeux autour de l'observation il y
a nécessaire partage des enjeux on
comprend bien quand on vous parle d'une
gestion affirmée par bassin en
subsidiarité ça veut dire que la gestion
affirmée par bassin dans l'approche
territorialisée différenciée il est
logique il y a un partage des enjeux à
ce niveau là et donc la question que je
me pose c'est vraiment ça comment c'est
partager
je dirais que ce qu'on peut en déduire
en filigrane c'est que c'est plutôt par
bassin qu'il faudrait définir
après une vérification de la gestion des
enjeux comment gérer au niveau du bassin
dans son ensemble
la difficulté c'est que le territoire le
bassin ne sont pas forcément calqué l'un
sur l'autre et que le
les départements et les bassins font pas
forcément calculer les uns sur les
autres
il y a quand même une communauté de
[Musique]
d'objets à gérer mais là et ça
appartient au législateur de dessiner
oui non parce qu'on a quand même
derrière on a des préfets coordonnateurs
de bassin et derrière les profs bassin
au niveau des services de l'État ils
doivent les organiser dans chaque
échelon régional des départementales
donc bon encore cette approche vous
voyez ce que je veux dire bon voilà
après la décliné même territorialement
quand je parle de l'acivilité sur les
sages les sages etc en relation ensuite
avec la maîtrise d'ouvrage sur leur
entre le grand cycle et le petit cycle
ça peut se faire quoi c'est pas
c'est pas incontournable en tout bon on
va pas passer trois heures là dessus
peut-être mais pour moi vous voyez ce
que je veux dire il y a un sujet il y a
un sujet de dire mais l'observation ou
la définition du spectre je me pose la
question de comment c'est c'est défini
comment c'est négocier voilà
juste pour finir je pense que votre
interrogation
ne doit pas dissocier du plan O
il va falloir le décliner et vous
touchez du doigt à la difficulté de
savoir comment il va décliner localement
au niveau du territoire on est d'accord
et derrière ça si je peux me permettre
c'est aussi il y a la question entre
guillemets qui est sous-jacente c'est
sur la protection des la protection des
zones de captage aussi n'oubliez pas on
est sur 500 zones de captage
prioritaires à l'heure actuelle donc il
y a aussi la question de l'élargissement
de la des zones de captage dites
prioritaire ou quelle est la politique
qu'on veut conduire aussi en la matière
et ça va de pair à ce que vous n’êtes
dire donc vous pouvez réagir aussi là
dessus ou qu'on mais c'est un sujet
qu'il faut poser aussi sur la table
c'est un sujet important il vous
concerne aussi vous directement
oui alors c'est un c'est un sujet
extrêmement vaste mais je j'ai quelques
quelques réflexions que j'ai vous
permettez je voudrais je voudrais
partager
d'abord
on efface aujourd'hui d'un nombre de
molécules absolument considérables et je
pense que ne peut que constater
malheureusement que la ressource en eau
porte la trace d'activité humaine
et et avoir une ressource en eau qui
serait indemne de toute trace de
d'activité humaine je pense que c'est un
peu aujourd'hui un peu illusoire donc
effectivement la politique sanitaire
alors
moi enfin en tant que opérateur d'eau
c'est évidemment pas à moi ni de ni de
[Musique]
fixer ni de critiquer ni de donner ma
position sur la politique sanitaire qui
est de la responsabilité des autorités
sanitaires
ce que je fais je constate et je vois
comment ça fonctionne donc politique
sanitaire ça consiste à essayer de
cibler quels sont les molécules qui sont
d'intérêt qui mérite d'être recherchés
dans un territoire donné
pour pour essayer de voir de quantifier
le risque dans ce territoire donné moi
ce que ce que j'ai pu voir c'est que le
ce que vous citez bon bah les ARS ont
reçu de la part de la direction générale
de la santé des lignes directrices pour
savoir comment en fonction de
l'historique des cultures qui a pu avoir
sur un territoire comment plutôt cibler
tel ou tel ou telle molécule bon c'est
des c'est des des lignes directrices on
ne peut pas chercher toutes les
molécules ça n'est pas possible alors je
voudrais juste faire une petite
parenthèse là dessus c'est pour ça qu'on
voit en ce moment beaucoup se développer
les les bio essais le bio essai c'est
des techniques qui consistent non pas à
chercher tel tel ou telle molécule parce
qu'on sait il y en a des milliers mais
qui consiste à essayer de voir quels
sont sur des organismes vivants l'effet
de tel ou telle qualité d'eau
oui c'est ça des traces des traces qui
peuvent voir de micropollions et donc
c'est boyc sont assez je pense que c'est
un potentiel assez intéressant dans ces
dans ces analyses de dans ces analyses
de risques pour en revenir sur le cap
plus spécifique parce qu'il est ça fait
quelques temps qu'il est assez mis en
avant puis encore très récemment dans
les médias pas plus tard qu'hier en cas
de métabolique de pesticides je pense
que là il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
sujets sur les enfin plusieurs niveaux
sur lesquels il faut agir évidemment le
préventif et vous l'avez cité les zones
de protection et captage enfin on voit
tout le débat qui a autour de ça
d'ailleurs le plan opporte un certain
nombre de mesures là-dessus évidemment
faut commencer par là maintenant on
constate que malheureusement le cas qui
est cité dans la presse ces jours-ci ça
porte sur une molécule qui est interdite
depuis plusieurs années donc là le
préventif c'est trop tard on est on est
dans le curatif il y a un deuxième
aspect me semble-t-il important c'est
l'aspect de la connaissance et de la
pédagogie la pédagogie parce qu'on est
sur des sujets qui sont complexes
complexes à expliquer entre le pertinent
non pertinent l'avait max etc enfin
c'est extrêmement complexe et or le
grand public a accès à l'information sur
la présence de telle ou tel molécule et
je pense que il doit y avoir un effort
fait de d'explication de toute cette
notion là de telle manière que le sujet
ne soit évidemment ni
sous-estimé ni de côté mais ni non plus
surestimé dans ses effets donc là il y a
sans doute de la pédagogie et concerne
qui est-ce qui doit le faire
la pédagogie bah écoutez c'est alors
il se trouve que je pense qu'au niveau
des acteurs de l'eau il y a un certain
nombre d'instances qui travaillent sur
ce sujet depuis de plus plusieurs mois
alors moi j'ai en tête par exemple le
l'aspect l'association scientifique et
dinglaude de l'environnement qu'un
groupe de travail suce ce sujet là qui
réunit beaucoup d'acteurs provenants
d'horizons différents donc des
collectivités des entreprises des
bureaux d'études etc pour essayer de
produire des éléments permettant de
d'aller dans ce sens là ça c'est un ça
c'est un exemple
et des éléments de langage qui soient
compréhensibles par tout le monde qui
soit compréhensible sans que ça soit
péjoratif c'est que le niveau moyen
d'accessibilité en termes de messages en
France c'est quatrième troisième seconde
au mieux et ne jamais oublier ça et
jamais
oui tout à fait parce que le le la
Direction Générale de la Santé a produit
des éléments de langage sur ces sujets
là mais désindlements de langage qui
sont et c'est pas leur faire un jour
parce que c'est normal c'est leur métier
administratif donc qui sont extrêmement
précis parce qu'ils doivent voilà mais
je pense que effectivement comme vous le
dites monsieur le rapporteur un peu
incompréhensible pour le voilà donc là
là il y a un gros gros travail à faire
je pense et sur l'information alors je
voudrais rajouter un élément qui me
paraît important sur l'information quand
on est face à des molécules qui sont
aujourd'hui interdites le problème que
l'on a vous savez que l'âne cesse va
classer les métabolites en pertinent en
pertinents en fonction de des risques
qui représente pour la santé mais l'un
de cesse adopte le principe que par
défaut si lui manque des informations il
va par défaut classé pertinent c'est à
dire principe de précaution j'ai pas
l'information suffisante je considère
que ce métabolite est pertinent doit
être traité comme la molécule mère et
c'est le cas par exemple de molécules
dont on parle ces jours-ci et la
difficulté
c'est que l'un de ces pourrait à partir
de nouveaux éléments revoir sa position
nouvelles études mais la difficulté sur
des molécules qui sont aujourd'hui
interdites c'est que les études
complémentaires de toxicité qui pourrait
être menées plus personne ne les fait
les molécules ne sont plus sur le marché
elles sont plus elles sont plus voilà
donc les fabricants ne font plus les
études et donc on se retrouve un peu
dans un dans un vide de connaissance
qui fait que on a une agence sanitaire
dit moi en l'absence de en l'absence de
connaissance
principe de précaution et donc là il y a
sans doute quelque chose à trouver en
terme de de d'amélioration de la
connaissance même sur ces même sur ces
molécules historiques interdites
aujourd'hui
et
si vous permettez alors très très
rapidement pardon mais et la dernière
chose c'est l'action la gestion
des problèmes quand une collectivité se
trouve confrontée à ce genre de problème
et là nous on a très bien senti face à
collectivités dans le groupe de train je
vous parle que les collectivités se
sentent un peu seul et en particulier un
petit peu regrettable mais les agences
de l'eau n'accompagnent pas forcément
les collectivités quand il s'agit de
curatif sur ces sujets là
et là les agences de l'eau vont être
très présentes quand il s'agit de
préventif mais quand il s'agit de
curative beaucoup moins or comme je l'ai
dit bah le curatif malheureusement ça
n'est plus que la solution qui qui reste
quand on est sur des molécules
interdites très bien des plafonnants on
va peut-être y répondre on y va un peu
près il y a la question si je suppose
que la recherche malgré tout vous permet
d'avancer sur ces sujets là mais en même
temps on en comprend la complexité c'est
délicat peut-être monsieur Ribaut donc
ou autre collègue je vous en prie
maintenant rapidement donc souscrit à
tout ce que vient de dire lambrunet
il y a un point qui est directement en
écho à ce que vous demandez monsieur
rapporteur qui est la disponibilité des
méthodes analytiques par des
laboratoires à crédités et que c'est
c'est un élément qui progresse donc que
ce soit dans les groupes ou que ce soit
dans la recherche publique mais c'est un
des facteurs limitants et et à mesure
que la recherche analytique sensu
stricto se développe on trouve de
nouvelles molécules sur lesquelles dont
on se préoccupe en disant bon et est-ce
que qu'en est-il il avait max etc il y a
des il y a des temps de dégradation qui
sont très différents au niveau des
molécules aussi donc il y a forcément
des priorités à fléchés par rapport à
certaines qui se dégradent beaucoup plus
vite enfin je sais pas mais c'est un
sujet aussi
oui oui tout à fait
je souscris à 100% à ce que vous venez
de dire monsieur le rapporteur le
une difficulté que Laurent a mentionné
c'est entre guillemets la pollution
orpheline parce que le produit a été
retiré du marché on est typiquement dans
ce cas là donc depuis 2019 ou
historiquement et donc effectivement il
y a cet effet il y a cet effet rémanent
il y a l'efférer maintenant des produits
de dégradation qu'on retrouve
éventuellement 10-15 ans 20 ans parfois
après la après l'interdiction d'usage et
à ce moment-là on se préoccupe on dit ah
tiens ce produit et maintenant il est
très présent que sait-on de cette
toxicité et évidemment la société qui
avait mis sur ça sur le marché il y a de
ça 20 ans d'écouter moi je travaille
plus dessus je ne la vends plus donc il
y a une vraie difficulté à ce niveau là
on l'a bien noté pas de souci peut-être
qu'on vous demandera une contribution
particulière parce que ça nous prendrait
trop de temps sur l'évolution de la
randée la recherche d'un développement
aussi sur ces sujets là ça nous
intéresserait alors après il y a entre
la recherche et aussi le fait que elle
va se traduire sur le terrain en terme
de capacité aussi technologique à
pouvoir mettre en place et dans les
conditions économiques c'est aussi sans
doute un sujet difficile mais si vous
pouvez nous nous donner quelques
éléments d'appréciation
ça serait intéressant je vous propose
d'avancer encore un petit peu plus
peut-être dans les dans le questionnaire
qu'on a pu avoir alors peut-être qu'on
va puisque on a un laps de temps
maintenant qui se réduit un petit peu
revenir pour le coup sur le plan où on a
déjà abordé quelques sujets particuliers
mais il y en a d'autres que je pense que
vous souhaiteriez aborder il y en a
qu'on souhaiterait vraiment aborder
aussi par rapport à la gestion c'est
bien sûr la tarification différenciée
ciée qui est un sujet qui est quand même
très important mais c'est un sujet
relativement complexe quand on y regarde
d'un peu plus près jusqu'où on pose le
curseur de la tarification différenciée
au niveau des usages
si on y met juste on va jusqu'au bout
est-ce que tous les usages vont être
concernés par la tarification
différenciée en tout cas il y a déjà un
petit conflit gouvernemental entre
l'agricole et
l'environnement déjà sur ce sujet on
peut le noter donc des sujets que vous
souhaitez mettre en perspective en
complément sur le plan o que nous
n'aurions pas abordé et notamment sur la
tarification différenciée est-ce que on
reprend par le bas pour remonter à ce
moment-là monsieur Ribaute vous démarrez
sur
cette tarification
différenciée donc qui est
différent du sujet de tarification
sociale mais entre nous on est on est
bien d'accord c'est juste pour m'assurer
que j'avais bien compris
donc c'est un bon point alors c'est vrai
que
moi je dis donc dans quel objectif dans
l'objectif de maîtriser la trajectoire
des consommations et de ne pas subir des
arrêts brutaux dans dans l'accès à la
ressource donc
c'est vrai que
dans ma réflexion j'ai tendance à le
lier à la thématique du comptage c'est à
dire
il faut que chacun puisse maîtriser sa
consommation donc quand on a des relevés
qui sont manuels
une deux fois par an compliqué d'avoir
voilà c'est comme conduire un véhicule
et vouloir respecter les accords
une fois une fois qu'on a dit ça
c'est effectivement cette c'est un c'est
un des moyens de d'avancer sur une une
maîtrise une maîtrise des consommations
donc c'est un point
c'est un point c'est un point qui est
qui est intéressant et sur lesquels il y
a des gens des initiatives on pense dans
les zones touristiques avec la
tarification saisonnière voilà par
exemple donc ça ce qui permet sur lequel
on échange qui est intéressant aussi
parce que la tarification saisonnière
entre la fois le tourisme et parfois le
cycle climatique
et souvent ça souvent ça se percute
puisque en général les touristes enfin
hormis en zone de montagne en hiver
viennent dans des zones de bord de mer
où il y a un enjeu sur la ressource et
au moment où elle fait souvent le plus
cruellement défaut donc voilà donc on a
déjà des expériences en la matière et et
ce qu'on voit c'est que en combinant on
va dire donc la mesure l'information
de l'usager
de l'accompagnement sur son comportement
c'est-à-dire attention là vous approchez
d'une certaine limite peut-être mettre
le mettre dans en relation avec une
collectivité d'usagers ou comparer
lui-même par rapport au monde de sa
famille par rapport à ses voisins par
rapport à son quartier
en mettant en place aussi parfois des
équipements complémentaires chez les
chez les particuliers je pense en
particulier à des réducteurs de pression
ou des éléments dans les dans les
sanitaires voilà pour ceux qui n'ont pas
encore eu le moyen de s'acheter des des
chasses à double vitesse il y a eu des
programmes européens à un moment donné
d'accompagnement aménagé ce qu'on
observe c'est que la conjonction de ces
différentes mesures permet de maîtriser
les consommations et d'observer des
baisses de consommation et là où ça
devient intéressant s'ils sont sans
pénaliser l'usage et ressembler dans un
côté punitif c'est-à-dire tu ne feras
pas si tu ne feras pas ça mais c'est on
est dans une action où la personne
volontaire et ne pas pénaliser le
concessionnaire ça veut dire que il y
aura forcément des évolutions peut-être
tarifaire entre le prix de l'abonnement
du forfait initial et comment trouver le
modèle économique qui permet je vends
moins de mètres cubes d'eau mais en même
temps je continue de fonctionner
économiquement
les services d'eau c'est pas une
économie du coup du coup zéro quoi c'est
à dire que qui est en face passer de
l'eau ou pas dans les tuyaux les
infrastructures elles sont là et bien
pour ça que je vous pose la question il
y aura forcément une évolution derrière
ça il faut rentrer un peu dans le dur du
sujet donc
écoutez aujourd'hui rien n'empêche de le
faire on a déjà des on a déjà des
contrats qui sont basés à des objectifs
de performance sur sur des engagements
de réduction des volumes unitaires donc
ça fonctionne déjà en fait donc on n'est
pas la forme la forme contractuelle
actuelle permet
vous avez pas toujours les connaissances
nécessaires de faire une tarification
différenciée au niveau du ménage nombre
de personnes c'est pas forcément croisé
toutes ces données à l'heure actuelle or
si on veut y aller il va falloir les
croiser
une personne qui est dans son logement
s'il y en a deux il y en a trois il y en
a quatre donc il va falloir adapter la
tarification différentielle la nature du
ménage donc c'est des questions de fonds
de croisement d'un faux de données etc
et d'adaptation et je parle bien du
particulier je ne suis pas rentré
maintenant sur l'activité économique
après là au moins on m'a on va dire ma
compétence s'arrête là c'est sur
notamment toute la ce que vous évoquez
moi ça ça soulève chez moi la question
de la protection des données et de la
vie personnelle des gens donc là je suis
pas en mesure
je bouscule un petit peu là dessus
volontairement c'est parce que derrière
ça nous ce qu'on va essayer de mesurer
c'est dans quelle mesure vous êtes prêts
et quelles sont les difficultés que vous
allez avoir et derrière les difficultés
que vous allez avoir c'est nous en
termes de proposition voire même
législative normative ou pourquoi pas
réglementaire en termes de proposition
gouvernement on peut aller un peu plus
loin assez rapidement parce que ce sujet
va monter en puissance assez rapidement
donc c'est pour ça que je pousse un peu
le trait volontairement voilà vous
sentez pas trop brusqués mais je permets
juste ça me fait penser qu'un mot au
point que vous évoquez avant cet
indicateur de performance
quelle est l'intention de la maîtrise
d'ouvrage c'est quoi son objectif qui
normalement se traduit dans le cahier
des charges et dans la consultation je
pense que c'est ça l'enjeu en fait c'est
déjà beaucoup d'outils beaucoup d'outils
sont là
mais ensuite une assise la notion de
contrat de performance et d'objectif à
s'imposer de plus en plus dans des
éco-conditionnalités et des objectifs
qui seront assignés par toutes les
structures qui vont co-financer les
maîtrises d'ouvrages pour faire court
c'est dans ce sens là où il va y avoir
aussi du développement parce qu'on
pourra pas de toute manière avancer
d'une manière durable si on crée pas ces
conditions là ce qui commence à déjà
être le cas de certaines politiques des
agences de l'eau mais
c'est relativement partial mais ça
commence à être le cas donc la batterie
va être devrait être complète
logiquement sur le sujet si on essaye de
peut-être avant que vous répondiez tous
les trois sur la consommation d'eau par
ménage parce qu'on est sur le 120 mètres
cubes mais en réalité si on enlève les
gros consommateurs qui ne sont pas des
ménages à combien enfin il me semble
qu'on est plutôt autour de 90 mètres
cubes au 80 voilà est-ce que vous avez
des données plus précises là dessus pour
savoir d'où on part et où on doit aller
parce que les 120 mètres cubes je pense
que c'est pas une réalité aujourd'hui
c'est la base utilisée pour la
tarification le prix au mètre cube mais
quand on observe les consommations
enfin bon moi je sais que sur ma
structure on n'est pas à ce niveau là
donc je voulais avoir vous qui avez une
vision un peu macro votre avis
enfin on essayera d'apporter des
réponses par écrit là-dessus parce que
la bonne question elle est précise alors
on a des histogrammes de consommation
après ça est-ce que vous parlez du de la
médiane de la moyenne
il y a quelques nuances d'ordre
statistiques
on s'efforcera là j'ai passé en tête
voilà donc mais effectivement qui là
c'est structurant on est d'accord
les chiffres que vous dites madame
effectivement c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs on ne peut pas oui 80 100
mètres cubes
de la distribution
objectifs
c'est entre 80 à 90 et 80 m3
énormément de votre configuration d'où
vous êtes géographiquement de situation
et puis dans le sud il consomme plus
ainsi de suite et encore c'est pas
toujours évident parce que
ah oui plus on va consommer
peut-être réagir suite rapidement parce
que c'est intéressant ce soir du 120
mètres cubes c'était la référence il y a
ouais c'est ça ouais et donc ça veut
dire que depuis 20 ans ma légende c'est
plus 120 c'est plus 90 c'est moins
beaucoup et en fait mais ça veut dire
que finalement
ça se retrouve aussi dans ce qu'il paye
d'ailleurs que en fait le le
quand on compare 120 m3 120 mètres cubes
aujourd'hui la facture 120 mètres cubes
aujourd'hui c'est une facture d'un gros
consommateur alors qu'il y a 20 ans
c'est une facture voilà donc ça c'est
intéressant sur la la référence la base
alors moi je crois que le temps de vous
écouter j'avais deux deux choses donc
sur la tarification rapidement
effectivement dans ce qui a été dit moi
je le partage et je le partage et
monsieur le rapporteur le sujet est
extrêmement complexe c'est tout sauf
simple la tarification donc de dire
franchement c'est c'est extrêmement
complexe il faut bien mesurer les effets
et les effets induits de la tarification
parce qu'il y a des effets on est sur la
consommation on est sur le social on est
sur etc donc c'est c'est un sujet
compliqué une remarque quand même
enfin en tout cas quelques grandes
villes à l'international qui ont se sont
retrouvés face à des risques très forts
de de rupture d'eau ont mis en place des
des tarifications spécifiques de crise
mais pour pour vraiment que ça ait un
effet très très fort il faut vraiment y
aller très fort si je puis dire donc et
ça pose une question cette quand même
cet élasticité entre prix et
consommation pose un peu une question
sur la vraie valeur de l'eau c'est à
dire partir du moment en augmentant un
peu le prix de l'eau mais les gens
consomment tout autant ça pose la
question mais mais finalement est-ce que
la valeur de l'eau est vraiment perçue
bon ça c'est je pense que c'est une
question qui mériterait d'être
développé je me permets je il y a quand
même un message que je voulais passer
sur le plan haut qui change complètement
de sujet mais c'est que j'ai quand même
un petit regret si vous me permettez de
l'exprimer sur ce plan haut
c'est que je trouve que ce plan aborde
très peu le volet assainissement il
aborde à travers la réutilisation des
eaux usées traités mais sinon il
abordent très peu hors l'eau et
l'assainissement finalement c'est un
seul et même sujet je pense qu'on est
tous d'accord pour dire c'est un site
c'est un seul et même sujet et en ce
moment au niveau européen est en
discussion la révision de la directive
européenne sur les originaires
urbaines qui est une directive qui va
structurer l'assainissement dans tous
les pays européens pour les 30 années à
venir c'est un c'est un projet qui porte
des enjeux ambitieux qu'on a abordé en
partie tout à l'heure on a parlé des de
la pollution alors on s'est focalisé sur
les pesticides mais tout le sujet des
autres micropollions résidus
microplastiques résidu mais comment
médicamenteux etc
le plan n'en parle pas ce projet de
révision de la directive européenne en
parle
le pluvial la gestion du pluvial est
quand on parle de gestion du stress
hydrique ben on parle des
imperméabilisation des villes etc la
directive européenne le projet directive
européenne en parle et nous si on avait
un souhait c'est que ce sujet là soit
également porté politiquement comme est
porté politiquement le sujet autour du
plan haut actuellement oui on en a tout
à fait conscience vous faites bien de de
le souligner
et bon on a malheureusement pas le temps
d'aborder tous les tous les sujets mais
les microplastiques par exemple sont un
sujet qui prend aussi une dimension
particulièrement forte et à mon avis
elle va la prendre cette dimension et se
renforcer encore aussi sur ces sujets là
donc
on le note bien en tout cas
monsieur Bardy peut-être sur la
tarification différenciée
je vais quand même aborder plusieurs
juger dont celle là parce que je pense
que on arrive au débats et de conclusion
on reviendra auprès de Monsieur Ribaut
aussi s'il veut apporter les aimants il
y a pas de souci mais il faut nous
sommes dans un flux d'actualité qui est
assez fourni en la matière et donc cette
commission tombe à point nommer vous
avez abordé nous avons échangé sur un
certain nombre de sujets dont celui de
l'évolution de contractuelle et
l'évolution de du climat
alors en premier lieu et en plus je sors
du sujet technique même si dans le
groupe sort nous avons développé des
technologies vraiment adéquates pour
traitement de tout ce qui est Micropole
vous voulez pas les partager avec vous
je veux juste redonner à ce que nous
avons fait nous-mêmes la juste valeur
comme il vous appartient ainsi qu'au
reste de nos concitoyens de redonner à
l'eau sa juste valeur
et donc à ce sujet je vais vous dire moi
que le plan O est une excellente idée
une excellente idée mais il faut pas
s'arrêter là
on parle dans le plan haut de du plafond
mordant et oui dans l'une des questions
que vous avez fait parvenir je pense que
c'est une excellente idée de le
supprimer
il faut redonner à l'école française de
l'eau ce qu'il a créé à un moment donné
l'eau pélo
il faut la considérer à son juste niveau
et à sa juste valeur
on parle dans dans le plan o de libérer
de l'ordre de 500 millions d'euros de
travaux de fonds supplémentaires pour
les agences de l'eau je rappelle que aux
assises de l'eau il a eu un certain
nombre de réflexion
partagée par la communauté des acteurs
dans le domaine de l'eau l'État les
différents entités gouvernementales etc
l'administration et les valorisations
qui étaient donnés à l'époque c'était
un sur
un investissement supplémentaire de 3
milliards par an pendant 5 ans pour
essayer de rattraper le niveau des
problèmes que nous avions à ce moment-là
au niveau de des fuites des perditions
et problèmes des rendements je rappelle
que ces chiffres là dataient d'avant le
covid d'avant l'Ukraine d'avant
l'envolée de matière première d'avoir
l'inflation on l'a bien noté même sur la
rénovation des réseaux on parlait à un
moment donné d'un plan Marshall et de
plusieurs milliards d'euros exactement
donc
on est bien d'accord je souhaitais qu'on
garde ces chiffres en tête avant de
poursuivez plus vos travaux en tout cas
que vous arrivez à une conclusion et et
je dirais
on parle de guichet unique c'est encore
une fois une excellente idée vous avez
parlé vous-même des problèmes qu'on
avait avec des entités qui décidaient de
manière autonome de manière locale et
sans une coordination au niveau du
bassin très bien mais allons plus loin
ce guichet unique donnons-lui
donnons-lui plus d'autonomie plus de de
flexibilité et plus d'agilité dans la
décision savez-vous que nos agences de
l'eau sont plusieurs il n'a pas qu'une
en moyenne une agence de l'eau pour
aboutir un dossier en moyenne au niveau
national a besoin de 37 signatures avant
de débloquer un sujet
je pense qu'à ce moment-là la création
de ces signatures à vérifier
mais faisons-le et je dirais que si vous
arrivez à libérer ces contraintes avec
la création de Michel unique mais qui
soit agile autonome il puisse être
calqué au niveau du bassin allons-y et
il faudra mettre plus de 500 millions
oui c'est un sujet intéressant alors
pareil on ouvre des tiroirs mais on
essaye de regarder d'un peu plus près
comment on s'y la contractualisation
peut s'affirmer quand on parle des
bassins mais ensuite
au travers des compétences des
collectivités concernées les régions
montent en puissance à l'heure actuelle
sur le sujet petit à petit on pourrait
très bien envisager que les contrats de
plan est en région soient renforcés
maintenant dans une dimension haut les
contrats cette dimension est
complètement absente à l'heure actuelle
ou très peu il y a parfois des
coopérations mais c'est pas toujours
aussi affirmé vous voyez ce que je veux
dire et du coup peut-être créer des
agilités territoriales dans la
décentralisation qui nous permettrait
d'aller un peu plus vite un peu plus
fort mais aller plus vite elle est plus
fort j'ai abordé le volet financement
je dirais que il y a ce problème de
financement qui existe vous faites un
plan o un guichet unique je propose en
tout cas l'idée de créer un fond
pour les problèmes que l'on doit traiter
je vous invite à vous à vous intéresser
à ce qui se passe en Suisse ou la
Confédération suisse a mis en place un
fort spécifique pour tout ce qui est
traitements de micropoles à fond de 2
milliards de francs suisses avec un
système de bonus malus au collectivité
si ils allaient pas d'ores et déjà dans
le traitement de Micropole oui juste
puisque là
on essaie de regarder les pistes
éventuellement de travail sur le fait
que le plafond mordant saute aujourd'hui
on pourrait très bien considérer qu'il y
a une enveloppe qui est nationalisée
dans ce cas de figure qui permettrait de
financer des grands chantiers ou des
grands sujets vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
on déplaphone le plafond mordant et du
coup on va mutualiser une partie aussi
des ressources qui sont dégagées mais
sur des grands chantiers qui sont
partagés au niveau national et justement
si vous permettez c'est un peu le
corollaire c'est vous avez
vous avez la libéralisation de du
fonctionnement entre palibarisation au
sens extrême du terme mais en tout cas
donner une agilité avec une unité de
lieu de temps et d'action au niveau des
décisions au niveau au territorial
calqué sur le bassin si vous le
souhaitez mais donner également les
fonds qui vont avec et je dirais au lieu
d'avoir un système qui est celui
d'aujourd'hui vous parle dans le plan on
parle de 170 communes qui ont des
problèmes au lieu de se disperser avec
10% de financement de 170 communes sont
des projets qui n'auront peut-être
jamais le jour choisir les 10 15 20 30
projets qui sont une cause nationale et
mettre ces fonds là pour les financer et
faire quelque chose de pragmatique de
rapide on n'est pas très éloigné de ce
point de vue d'autres réactions pour ce
que Monsieur Bardy c'est bon
la tarification sociale
c'est une très bonne idée parce qu'une
idée d'équité derrière donc je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le fait qu'il y a
quand même un problème de gestion
en tarification sociale et différenciée
aussi mais il y a pas de souci alors on
poursuit la phase de la conclusion
revient peut-être à Monsieur Ribaute et
puis monsieur Brunet si vous rajoutez
aussi quelques éléments sur une autre je
vous en prie
donc oui
déjà un point en ce qui concerne
l'intervention des régions ce serait une
bonne nouvelle que ça s'approfondisse
pour une raison tout à fait facile à
comprendre c'est que les régions
administrent les aides européennes
aujourd'hui c'est un angle mort pour
elle la politique de l'eau
pas majeure en tout cas à partir du
moment où elles auraient un rôle à jouer
il y aura vraiment une efficacité
intéressante à rechercher de ce point de
vue là l'autre point auquel vous avez
largement fait allusion qui était les
contrats de performance
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui nous
tient à cœur et par rapport à la
création d'un fond ou ce genre de choses
il faut absolument lier les deux l'usage
de l'argent doit être conditionné de
cette façon là de telle sorte que
comment je dirais
il y a une prime à la performance et non
pas à la non performance
voilà
très bien monsieur Brunet est-ce que
vous avez donc on va conclure cette
table ronde Florence je t'en prie
avoir sujet on a parlé interconnexion
tout à l'heure et c'est essentiel mais
parfois l'interconnexion conduit à dire
on a une petite source là qui fonctionne
mais pas très bien l'été et on abandonne
des sources qui pourtant ont alimenté
des communes pendant
des décennies voire des siècles donc
certains élus nous alertent beaucoup sur
le risque d'abandonner des sources qui
qui vient souvent assez vite après une
interconnexion donc quel est votre avis
vous sur le sujet
oui ben je pense qu'on gestion de la
rareté toute ressource doit être doit
être doit être préservé ça c'est évident
parfois ce qu'on voit la difficulté des
des petites sources c'est la difficulté
de leur contrôle de leurs qualités donc
il faut arriver à assurer évidemment ce
contrôle cette maîtrise de la qualité
mais à partir du moment où cette
maîtrise de la qualité est faite
évidemment il faut il faut maintenir il
faut garder toutes les toutes les
ressources disponibles
en mettant en perspective la notion de
qualité
parce que la quantité qui a un point
important mais la qualité donc là dans
les cas concrets parce que ça représente
des choses concrètes dans votre esprit
des exemples que vous donniez est-ce
qu'il y a des enjeux de qualité de ses
ressources
et ça c'est l'élément aussi regarder
encore l'air il y a l'interrogation
aujourd'hui sur toute l'optimisation de
la ressource on parlait l'exemple de
Bordeaux avec les champs captant du
Médoc pour préserver les nappes
profondes bon c'est des projets très
lourds et conséquent mais derrière il y
a d'autres stratégies que la métropole
aussi développe c'est-à-dire on va
prélever dans la Garonne on va utiliser
des anciennes gravières comme
puifiltrant un moment donné pour
récupérer l'eau dans les meilleures
conditions pouvoir la injecter c'est
juste des exemples mais voilà il y a
un certain nombre aussi de réflexions
pour dire comment on arrive aussi
optimisé la ressource mais cette
question là aussi c'est une question
partagée c'est une question de fond
parce que plus ça va aller sur les
grandes agglos là on a vraiment une
pression de plus en plus forte en termes
de densité etc plus la nécessité de
trouver des ressources complémentaires
négociées comme je disais tout à l'heure
avec tout ce que ça suppose ça va être
de plus en plus fort c'est évident
évident de plus en plus fort donc
la stratégie de l'optimisation des
ressources et de
de de nouveaux process pour utiliser des
ressources qu'on n'avait pas imaginées
aujourd'hui c'est un sujet qui
effectivement vient de plus en plus
important bon après sur la route etc
nous on a déjà un peu abordé le sujet on
est toujours surpris quand l'ARS nous
dit mais il y a aucun souci on peut tout
faire aujourd'hui enfin j'exagère je
pousse le train mais c'était un peu
quand même hier en nous disant mais sur
l'irrigation agricole etc on peut
largement utiliser la route il y a pas
de souci à l'heure actuelle j'avais pas
ce retour là moi si vous voulez ça me
semblait un petit peu plus compliqué je
voulais attirer quand même votre
attention juste à la fin
un des sujets sur lequel on travaille
aussi c'est l'amélioration de la
planification de la gestion de l'eau
vous avez compris s'inversant mais on
regarde comment au travers des
collectivités on donne encore plus de
sens sur la gestion de l'eau avec
peut-être aujourd'hui à s'interroger sur
la place des régions en lien avec les
autres collectivités territoriales mais
dans le cas de l'amélioration de la
planification une réflexion c'est dans
le cas des scottes mettre aussi affirmer
la gestion de la ressource dans le cas
des scottes parce que quand on accueille
des habitants un Scott il est fait pour
accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions si un habitant des habitants
le but du jeu c'est de réfléchir sur
avec quelles ressources énergie il y a
les déchets et il y a l'eau donc le fait
d'avoir une vision affirmée de la
gestion de l'eau dans les scottes en
termes de document planification c'est
intéressant enfin ça nous semble
intéressant de même que les scottes à ce
moment là vont avoir des niveaux de
prescription au niveau des pluies et des
PLU de telle manière à avoir une vision
plus précise de la gestion de l'eau et
d'avoir une gestion plus précise du fil
de l'eau et notamment du pluviale
on peut s'interroger aussi sur
l'optimisation de la gestion du pluvial
à l'heure actuelle est-ce que il faut
forcément des réseaux séparatifs est-ce
que dans le cas du développement de
zones intelligentes etc vaut mieux pas
que le pluvial air sur des secteurs qui
sont repérés etc pour avoir une gestion
plus prospective et stratégique du fil
de l'eau et donc le fait de travailler
sur des documents de planification et de
l'intégrer permet d'avoir une vision
plus commune et plus partagée plus
stratégique voilà je voulais vous
l'indiquer parce que ce sont des pistes
de travail qui sont qui peuvent être
importantes pour vous aussi
à moyen terme voilà
bien monsieur le Président on va on va
conclure
a fini de poser ces questions en effet
merci à vous en tous les cas d'être venu
participer à cette table ronde
pour nous c'est important dans cette
mission c'est important d'avoir votre
c'était important d'avoir votre vision
des choses et puis de pouvoir échanger
avec notre apporteur notamment et avec
les collègues qui étaient là enfin la
collègue en l'occurrence parce que
aujourd'hui c'est un peu compliqué
on aurait pu avoir plus de monde mais
avec les transports il y a beaucoup de
collègues qui sont partis hier soir
et on peur de pas avoir de train
aujourd'hui en avion donc voilà ce qui
explique le fait qui est moins de
sénateurs que d'habitude mais en tous
les cas ce sera dans le rapport tout ça
et grâce à vous on va on va essayer
d'avancer voilà merci à vous je vous
souhaite une nouveauté une bonne journée
merci et merci au service pour tout le
boulot qui font
[Musique]